anna you are the most extraordinary  person i've ever known  i love you with all i am  will you marry me welcome back to the  things disney fans  at the end of frozen two kristoff  proposes and anna becomes queen of  arendelle  so frozen 3 would definitely have to  feature the couple's long-awaited  wedding right  we're imagining what that special day  would look like right down to the very  last detail  honest gown and accessories kristoff's  suit and crown  the magical place where they say their  vows which guest do you think would  attend this most happy of occasions  watch as we present to you the moment  that anna and christoph make it official  congrats to the new king and queen of  [Music]  arendelle  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you